please let me be the first to punch the
next person who tells you everything
happens for a reason I'm sorry you're
going through this I'm a designer and
illustrator and writer and we make
products like greeting cards and tote
bags and dish towels and 50 things that
tell the truth and speak to people when
I was sick the kind of cards that I got
more either get well soon cards which
are weird if you have a serious illness
and you might not get well because
you're like okay cool I'll try it's not
people's fault it's just we don't do a
very good job
culturally at talking to people about
how to behave around illness
I would have loved to receive that part
just from somebody being honest and
saying I'm really sorry I haven't been
in touch I didn't know what to say that
would have meant a lot to me